hi i'm carter and i'm drew we're seven
years old and today we're going to
have two chefs compete to make our
dream dish
[Music]
hi boys i'm alexis and i'm alex i'm
carter
nice to meet you nice to meet you too so
boys we have a question for you
what would a wizard serve at a feast
like a dragon feast
so carter andrew said they wanted a
dragon feast and i can
already tell that this is going to be
crazy so is the dragon eating this feast
or
or does it taste like dragon no the bad
dragon the good drug
we're brothers and the bad dragon eats
meat so that's what he's trying to get
but the good
dragon only like eats fruit and
vegetables
[Music]
all right i think i need a little help
picturing this would you boys draw it
for us
yes what's this pink you're drawing it's
like the evil stuff
and so what does that taste like i don't
know what it tastes like because
like if you eat it you turn evil so i
don't want to turn evil
the purple which is evil
i don't even know and he has one two
three four five
six eyes six six eyes i'm loving the
detail here on these
dead eyes so i'm really gonna try to
incorporate that into my
dish so the wings here we go do you know
what those taste like
um they like taste like like a meat bar
meat bar wings that tastes like a meat
bar
i have a couple of ideas but still
really weird the legs are bacon bacon
bacon
okay finally something easy i'm gonna
put straight up bacon on the plate
like what are your favorite vegetables
uh broccoli
broccoli i think drew and carter are the
only kids i've ever met that
actually like broccoli and not just like
it but love it
so do you like broccoli hold what do you
eat get cut
up you eat at home parents must be proud
wow this is a masterpiece and then this
is the sauce
i think we have our work cut out for us
i think so
all right let's go make some magic okay
[Music]
that's impossible so here's my plan for
the body of my dragon i'm gonna use a
giant chicken nugget for the head
i'm gonna try to make a quesadilla and
i'll dye the cheeses
the colors of the drawing so purple and
green for the wings i'm gonna make
burger patties and for the legs just
some bacon for the evil stuff
i'm gonna make mashed potatoes and i'm
gonna dye them purple
and to keep it consistent with a drawing
i'm gonna put three pieces of broccoli
some pieces of pineapple and the very
oddly specific lines of barbecue sauce
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
make a dragon out of meatloaf
and then i'm gonna make wings out of
like a maple
bacon hard candy and then make a
kind of like a fruit broccoli salad
around and then have the bacon
as the legs all around they said the
purple stuff was evil and that you'll
die if you eat it so
i'm just gonna admit it like why even
give them the option
oh hey well that was weird so i'm gonna
start with my
giant chicken nugget i'm gonna put two
pounds of meat in my bowl
onion powder and some garlic powder
i'm gonna keep the seasonings for this
pretty basic i really gotta get this
into the freezer so it has some time to
firm up and i'm gonna just
form kind of a patty or not a patty the
body of the
dead dragon um it unfortunately does
look like cat food right now
ew oh i hate cat food once i ate cat
food by accident
what yeah it was disgusting why i don't
know it's like on a fork
so for my meatloaf i'm going to
caramelize the
onions and garlic a bit so while my
onions
start to caramelize i'm just going to
get everything else ready ground beef
breadcrumbs eggs ketchup
salt pepper paprika and worcestershire
sauce i'm going to
start on my mashed potatoes and
i'm going to pop them in this feels like
my wizard cauldron
all right so now i'm gonna start on my
meat wings
just like you would shape a burger patty
i'm just gonna shape this into like a
wing
so i've won a couple of these and it
doesn't take away the anxiety but
i feel like i'm starting to understand
the process
a little more a lot of times meatloaf
you brush ketchup over it the boys have
been explicit that they hate ketchup
and they like barbecue sauce so that's
what i'm going to glaze the meatloaf in
i've never colored potatoes before so
i'm a little nervous
let's try oh yeah
it's looking pretty cool alex is making
these purple mashed potatoes
and i had this moment of panic where i
thought like oh god
maybe this is really crucial but i think
i have to stick with my gut and
totally admit it the boys said they
weren't gonna eat the evil i'm not gonna
make the evil
so the boys love broccoli so i have to
have it on there i'm gonna cut some
fruit
i've got papaya and kiwi i've got some
dragon fruit which is very fitting
dragon fruit in the dragon salad wham
you getting
fancy over there for vinaigrette the
ratio should be about three parts oil to
one part acid
i don't love the idea of broccoli and
fruit together but maybe the maple
vinaigrette will tie it all together
don't put the broccoli like in it but
like maybe like
like that decoration i wonder what's
gonna taste like
okay so my chicken nug is frozen solid
and i'm going to first
do a little bit of a dry coating in this
flour
now i'm going to dip this in my egg
wiggle that around
abercromb okay so i'm going to put my
chicken nugget in my
hot oil i've heated this up to about 350
degrees
just have to be very whoo okay
i'm a little bit worried about making
this giant chicken nugget because i
haven't even made a regular-sized
chicken nugget before
so i'm really excited about this i'm
gonna make the maple hard candy so i'm
gonna add
corn syrup maple syrup and then sugar
and then i'm gonna bring it to
a hard crack so so far my strategy has
been
sticking to the picture and using
flavors that i know kids like
and that's worked for me this far so i'm
gonna
do that again double double toil in
trouble
so my chicken nugget looks pretty good
it's golden brown i'm just gonna take it
off and put it on this rack to drain off
the excess oil
i had this crazy idea to try to
dye the cheese for the quesadilla purple
just gonna add
some food coloring to this shredded
mozzarella cheese
and mix it up to dye it purple
food coloring cheese is not that weird
have you ever cooked for kids
okay so this has reached 300 degrees and
you can see that it's become like this
kind of thick and syrupy
and this is my signal in addition to the
temperature that it is ready to go
i'm going to add the bacon to the maple
because they didn't like
things super sweet but hopefully this
will kind of like tie it all together
the die cut is spilled out from the
cheese onto the tortilla but i'm not
mad at it because you're able to see the
color a little bit more
what kid actually colors within the
lines so i'm making this maple
vinaigrette and it's actually
really really good i'm on track yeah get
me some of that fruit yeah
um right i actually
love that that wizardry am i right
i'm just gonna put my barbecue sauce in
a squeeze bottle so that it's easier to
control
[Music]
so it's time to plate this very weird
creation so i'm going to start with my
chicken nugget
honestly when i'm putting together my
dish it's pretty spot on
i have to say i'm looking down at my
dish i'm looking up at the picture and
it's looking it's looking pretty
accurate
then i'm gonna add my meat wigs
we have very different aesthetics going
on i have absolutely
no idea which way this could go i'm
gonna make some incisions to try to put
the wings into the meatloaf
once i put those wings into the meatloaf
i was like i mean there's no way they
can't choose this
okay this is hands down the most
ridiculous thing i have
ever made i'm done me too all right
let's go drag on these over to those
kids
when drew and carter were making this
drawing i was
really skeptical and as i've been
cooking i've just
i've gotten really into it and i
actually love how it turned out
i feel really optimistic about this one
it's definitely
not what they drew but i think drew and
carter are gonna like that it's
really imaginative and it's like a
dragon came to life
i think the boys are gonna love it i
also am confident in
all the flavors on my plate i know
there's a lot going on but
in my experience kids love all these
foods too
so i think we got ourselves a winner now
let's hope it tastes like their
imagination bring on the dragon feast
oh awesome good this looks like a huge
chicken nugget these look like
like stick and these look like bacon oh
and that's the head and those are the
two ears
this is mashed potatoes with food color
it's like play-doh or mashed potatoes if
it's mashed potatoes
because potatoes really who doesn't like
mashed potatoes
it doesn't really look like a dragon but
it looks good it looks just like our
picture
yeah is this like food coloring that's
baked
i have no idea i don't really know what
it tastes like
it smells like a tortilla tortilla it
looks like pizza
they're so fixated on the color of the
cheese that they're missing that it's
even cheese
okay i'm gonna try the broccoli
it's really good so it's so good
so good oh in the middle it's a chicken
nugget it's a chicken nugget
yeah my favorite part is
this head it's my favorite
it's a bacon and maybe the chicken like
it because it tastes like a dorito
it's just a very simple flower breading
so i'm not quite sure where they got
doritos from but they said that they
like doritos that looks just like a
dragon
look at this this looks like and this is
like
a head dragon this is like definitely
there's no evil part
maybe that's good it looks better than
what we drew
okay they said it's better than what
they drew i feel like i got this
tastes like chicken and barbies and
stuff i've never met for a long time so
i
can't really describe it this one's
probably like a lollipop candy thingy
they're very good but it'll be a little
better without the salt
the pineapples does not taste like a
pineapple it tastes better than the
pineapple okay when the boy said that
the pineapple tastes better than
pineapple i was like
that's the vinaigrette what is it is it
so strawberry no
you know what it's like what that is an
actual
dragon fruit
[Music]
my favorite part is this this might be
our
dinner today yeah this is going to be
our dinner today they are
really impressed with the lexuses i'm
sweating here
alakazam
hello hi guys hi so you two had two very
different dishes
which did you like better the chicken
nugget or the meatloaf
wow
that's mine oh alex
i guess this time i didn't slay the
dragon the dragon slayed me
because you won you get to have our
prize congratulations
thank you so much welcome i think
i think the magic was in my favor this
time it's a beautiful drawing
thank you
[Music]
you